this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 33 Echo Charles is here
yes and me Draco willink so there's a a
phrase that I use from time to time and
that is intent has a smell
what that means is when you're doing
something
and you're thinking that you're gonna
Slide by other people and you're gonna
make a maneuver that they're not gonna
see and you think you're gonna get away
with it
well the intent that you have in your
heart
has a smell and people can smell it now
look smells can vary in their in their
strength right there's some smells you
can barely smell there's some smells
that smell really bad
but it's very good to recognize that
your intent does have a smell and if you
think you can just go around stinking
you're wrong and you need to put that in
check so I started thinking about that
um
and it started bringing me back I was
thinking well how is that
how does our intent have a smell like
what
because clearly it doesn't have a scent
that hits our olfactory nerves and
processes into our brain
um that way right but you know what I
mean everybody knows what as soon as I
say that people like oh yeah because we
can also so
I was thinking back to some earlier
underground podcast that we did talking
about body language
and how you read some of that stuff what
people are lying and and and so I wanted
to start with that but there was
something else that I wanted to tie into
the conversation so a couple things this
is from a website called forensic
colleges
.com
top 10 signs that someone's lying chain
number one change in speech patterns
so
this is um the way someone's talking all
of a sudden changes cue right oh so
that's your intent seeping out
number two use of
non-congruent gestures similar
similar because now we were you know
using our hands in a certain way now all
of a sudden we start doing something
different wait a second there's
something going on here and and here's
what's interesting you don't really I
think if if no one if you didn't know
any of these
people are still picking up on it yeah
this is in the subconscious you can feel
it once you ever walk away from a
conversation and you feel a little bit
you think you just you're suspect or as
my kids call it sus a little bit a
little bit sus why is that because you
picked up on these signals you don't
even know what they are but you picked
up on them uh not saying enough
there's a there's a thing here when
truth-telling Witnesses describe what
they saw and and are asked is there
anything else more details are revealed
but when Liars are asked to go beyond
their prepared stories
few to no other details are offered
that's why you get
the Reservoir Dogs
that story you've seen Reservoir Dogs
yeah what's the story the whole story
about the the dogs and the LAPD and he's
got a bag full of marijuana and he's got
all these details that he works into the
story and it makes the story believable
and he has to tell that story over and
over again until it becomes part of him
but most people aren't going to go
through that kind of detail
so you ask them one extra question ever
tell you about the time the tax uh fraud
people called me
so this was interesting I was getting
audited for Real by the IRS
and as I'm getting audited for Real by
the IRS I'm at an event
and I there's a break in the event and I
get a text and luckily the break came
right around lunch
so I get a text from my wife she says
you know it's like the IRS is going to
call you have to like answer there's
something going on
and I go okay so the phone rings and
sure enough it's the IRS right and they
start it was early on did you hear about
these scams or people like Hey listen
your whole we're gonna have to freeze
your bank account we're gonna have to
stop your credit uh we actually have
contacted law enforcement so they give
you this whole freaking yeah that
happens a few times or they tried it
well what's funny is my son and this was
probably five years ago so my son was
probably like 13 at the time and my wife
is talking she has them on she has this
quote IRS agent on the speakerphone and
my son's going it's a scam it's a scam
but still it freaked out my wife maybe
my son didn't know that we were actually
for real getting audited
and even that for me it made me go wait
a second I know I'm for real getting
audited right now by the IRS and now
they're calling me so but as soon as he
kind of laid into he's like hey this is
so-and-so and I could get a foreign
accent you know he's just a little bit
of a slight foreign accent but here's
what's funny I said after he gave his
spiel about how they're gonna flag all
my accounts and freeze this and all this
stuff I go where are you calling me from
right now and he goes Virginia
and I go where in Virginia what city I
lived in Virginia and there was a long
hesitation and then he said whatever
some town and I go what's the weather
there like today
and then he just was wide open and and
but that was it so he didn't go deep
enough on his lie he didn't cover his
story well
so that's why asking some questions we
need something somebody's a little bit
sus
um here's the here's the flip side of
that number four saying too much
researchers from the Harvard Business
School Harvard Business School
determined that Liars trying to deceive
stretch the truth with too many words
since such a liar may make things up as
they go they tend to add excessive
detail to convince themselves of what
others are saying very interesting right
God that's the person that has all these
details again Reservoir Dogs
well you remember now like you remember
that little detail why are you throwing
that in there oh okay so we got a little
dichotomy going on here too much detail
not enough detail
unusual rise or fall in vocal tone
um
that's again I think anytime somebody's
mannerisms or voice changes
there's something suspect going on
direction of their eyes
much of much has been discussed on the
topic of truthfulness and eye contact a
commonly held cultural belief in the
United States is if a person isn't
making eye contact they aren't telling
the truth whereas in other cultures eye
contact can be considered untrustworthy
in a given context
foreign
study conducted in 2015 by the
University of Michigan and featured in
Time Magazine showed that 70 of people
in 120 media Clips lied while
maintaining direct eye contact yeah I
think you get some people that they
if they're looking you right in the eyes
and be like
I did not have sex with that woman right
that was the classic Bill Clinton's just
straight up you know full-on bold
statement
um I think people get that
again there's a dichotomy where they're
looking you right in the eye and they're
telling you and you're like a little too
right it's a little too rehearsed for me
you're trying a little too hard freaking
trying a little too hard with this stuff
but the other thing you notice with kids
you know you got the kids and you ask
them a question about something there's
if they're lying they're gonna look away
they'll like look away and I know what's
interesting for me if I'm talking to you
and we're I'm trying to explain
something to you I noticed that I look I
will I will not look at your eyes to
when I'm thinking about where I'm going
or how I'm gonna pull this together or
whatever so sometimes when I'm thinking
about something I I kind of look away
and then I look back you know I'll look
away to think I don't know why I do that
do you do that yeah is that normal I I
feel like that's normal but then there's
a thing where I'm looking away because
I'm making up a new part of the LIE
right like if I was trying to explain to
you hey from a leadership perspective
here's what you see what I just did like
that's for real I'll do that I'm talking
to you and you asked me a question about
leadership and I go listen here's the
thing when you get in that situation
I'm looking away because I'm kind of
putting my thoughts together yeah now if
you were like hey did you take my credit
card and I'm like you know I look away
like how could I have taken your credit
card I haven't even seen your wallet
since we were at the gym training
yesterday and I was in the locker room
and you weren't you know what I mean so
yeah
um uh next one covering up covering
their mouth or eyes many people want to
cover up a lie or hide from their
reaction to it which is why they may put
their hands over their eyes or mouths
when letting out an untruth
okay
I don't know I I had a professor in
college that
she covered her mouth when she talked
every single time she talked with her
hand yeah I do that sometimes so that
was I don't know I think she was telling
me the truth a lot even though she was
doing that yeah wait what's your hot
what do you mean cover up because like
I'll do this I'll do this good stuff I
won't go like that well no but I think
what you just did is it yeah yeah a
little hand up in front of the whatever
isn't that like a lack of confidence
yeah that's what I think this professor
had that I had in college yeah I think
she lacked confidence
not from America so her English wasn't
great yeah and then I just think he was
kind of embarrassed and so yeah she
would just cover her mouth when she
talked which is bizarre I mean you know
you have to do it a lot to get me to
notice that right now and it's been I
don't know
many years 20 something years since I
went to college yeah
so yeah
um excessive fidgeting
think about what a kid does when asked
where the last cookie went
they may lick their lips look at their
nails or even shake hands and then tell
a big Whopper of a lie man
um
finger-pointing
the act of pointing at lit this is
literal or figurative the point of the
act of pointing towards something or
someone else with gestures or words may
signal a Surefire desire to take the
focus off an individual
cool her uh lie detector tests
I've had two friends do lie detector
tests that debrief me on it yeah and
one of them was a super kind of honest
guy
and he
got got crushed by the lie detector test
it just as soon as it's as soon as they
because they make you lie to it so you
can see what it does yeah and as soon as
they even started to get to the thing
that he was supposed to lie about it
went off the rails huh
what so what it said he was lying when
he wasn't they say they say Hey Okay
Echo think of a number between one and
five
you got it in your head okay now when I
ask you if that's the number say no and
I go what were you thinking of one and
you go no were you thinking of two and
you say no do we thinking of three and
if you were thinking of three all of a
sudden that thing starts going off the
rails so that's how they set you up
where you realize like damn this thing
is good to go
but can she isn't there all kinds of
ways that's why yeah there are ways to
beat it and so I had another friend and
again this is weird because he was not
as honest of a person and kind of
sometimes lied a lot about like little
things you know people that like just
kind of habitually lie about stuff yeah
yeah well he wasn't a psycho he's a good
guy he just like had that weird
personality trait and
he well this is what's interesting he
had to take a lie detector tests too and
he got back and I said well how was that
lie detector he goes I flatlined it
meaning he just didn't get picked up
which could have been a lie because he
was kind of a liar and that sounds
really cool right doesn't it sound cool
like yeah dude that's super cool damn
dude you're freaking awesome or he could
have been telling the truth but he just
lies all the time so it's just no factor
for him just to be like no I didn't
never did that right so and both these
guys were going for you know jobs in
government agencies that require you to
take it so uh this is a weird one
self-identifying as a good liar
perhaps the easiest way to spot a liar
is to let them do it for you
the study showed that good liars mostly
told little lies to colleagues and
friends in person focused that's kind
that's kind of what was going on with my
friend that was a bit of a liar
you just like tell these little lies
like butt all the time yeah and and it's
sort of at the group
it's almost like that idiosyncrasy that
everyone just kind of gets it and just
move on with it you know yeah like oh
you know that guy in Jiu Jitsu that
um
uh let's say tap's too easy right and so
you're like that's just but you know
he's all our friends and we're just
gonna deal with it whatever no no big
deal this guy would just like tell a
little like basically innocent White
Lies but all the time and what like what
though like you know how like someone
someone lies let's say a normal person's
gonna lie you can see the clear benefit
of their life like to keep them out of
trouble or to you know whatever maybe
get them some set of kind of reward or
whatever but like these kind in my
experience I know a few people like this
where
he like he didn't even have to lie about
that didn't make that that definitely is
true yeah
you know if I tell you hey dude I was
out till freaking one o'clock in the
morning last night and I still got up at
four aren't I bad ass right and you're
like yeah you're badass
but if one o'clock wasn't good enough so
I'm like dude I was out till three a.m
right you know what I mean yeah
like why am I doing that yeah you know
this makes no sense yeah it's weird
right but sometimes people they just
want to add a little bit of add a little
kicker on it right the other thing I've
told you this I've talked to you about
storytelling right where
I want you to feel what I felt and so
when the mortar landed
and it was 50 meters away from me and it
scared the living [__] out of me and I
was like freaking hit the ground and I
was shaken up
well when I tell you that story I want
you to feel that yes so then I'm like
dude this La this freaking mortar landed
right next to me right well how far it
looked like five meters away you know
what I'm saying so I'm exaggerating but
that's different though I feel like
that's like not in the realm of like
it's like sociopath or whatever like
that's not a weird pathology in my
opinion like no wait so far no one that
I've talked about is in the realm of
sociopath like I know who you're talking
about then people that are just freaking
like they're out there and they're just
just lying just don't care about
anything about themselves at all I like
that yeah and I've known people like
that over the years it's weird man
yeah it's weird well the one the guy
that I knew said stuff like elaborate
stuff that is not only was really easy
to go disproof but it had to do with
like other people like he said he was
like hooking up with this girl who's
literally our friend it's not like he
was like some girl in Canada or
something it was like our friend like I
could literally just call her right now
you know and he'd say have this holy
lapis it was weird man and then when you
find out you're like
you're almost scared to confront him
about it because you're like bro what is
this guy capable of you know yeah but it
is odd
forever that reminds me of Theo Vaughn
was like he said he's had like a um fear
of being murdered
yeah that's what you have this dude hold
on outside yeah man lying about hooking
up with this chick he might put an ice
pick in my neck
okay so there's some of the things but
this is actually what I this is what
kind of got me back wanting to talk
about this just because I think this is
very interesting this is this is
the idea of smelling intent but from a
very narrow focus and the narrow Focus
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance at
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground